and let me do this let me pull up the
new york post store we got and we'll get
into this one
new york post quote um done with kovid
barry weiss on bill maher sparks
controversy not to us right cause like
we've been
i'm done with covet i think i said that
like four or five months ago and then i
got coveted and i got made fun of for it
no but it's it's the insanity of the
restrictions
so on friday on bill maher's show barry
weiss she said i'm done i'm done with
covid she said i sprayed the pringles
cans i bought at every grocery store i
stripped my clothes off because i
thought cover would be on my clothes i
watched tiger king i got to the end of
spotify we all did it i love that we all
did it
yo i'm sure a lot of these liberals did
so here's this is interesting
this is a mainstream corporate press
show bill maher bill maher's always been
kind of you know he he's always been in
line with the left in the culture war
but he's been he challenges that every
so often but he's late to the party he
gets things wrong so here i am i see
this going viral
first and most important thing good news
regular liberals who watch bill maher
are are now
cheering for this when barry weiss said
that what's happening to our kids will
be seen as a moral crime you know i'm
done with this everyone's clapping and
cheering
bill maher opened the show by saying he
called the vaccine a virtue signal that
was crazy to me he said your first dose
it's like i can't remember the exact
joke but he was like it comes in three
doses your your first series your
booster and your virtue signal and then
everyone
they laugh or whatever and so i'm like
this is really really good and i want to
make sure that's clear to everybody
because i'm going to criticize a bit of
everybody
it's good that we're watching regular
people wake up to this stuff it's good
that we're seeing people realize you've
got to do something about this
we can't just sit back and let the
country fall apart the stores are going
it's been two years right
but we've had this conversation a year
ago we had this conversation a year and
a half ago and my concern is just this
to all of the independent media types
the podcasters the twitter uh posters
the journalists who
have listened to this show listen to
stephen crowder who have listened to
jimmy dore jimmy door and crowder talked
about these things before we even did
so let's let's realize
we for one we were all right
what's the joke conspiracy theories 597
mainstream media zero you know we're
wondering this one uh
we talked about it first we were right
have more we need to have more
confidence in ourselves we need to
basically say to the likes of bill maher
but amongst ourselves is
we we need to set our own news cycle we
shouldn't sit back and be like well did
bill maher talk about it that's when it
matters no no we need to start acting
like the conversations we've already had
again like jimmy dore crowder stixxax
and hammer all these other independent
channels i've already had a long time
ago and when you go out to a restaurant
when you go out to uh i'll tell you this
there was that big breaking story where
the cdc lady i think it was said there's
a difference between dying from covenant
and dying with covet right cnn picks it
up and goes crazy yo we talked about
that a year and a half ago yeah so when
you're when you're at the bar and
someone's saying yeah but did you hear
how many people you know died today you
can go
yeah i mean but you're not conflating
within four i mean that was they've
already they've already explained that
don't you watch don't you pay attention
just
stop acting like cnn is is who should be
setting the news cycle that's what i'm
saying yeah for sure i mean as you said
some of these things have been around i
mean there was that early period in
covert where nobody really knew what was
going on
and then once we got to like mid
you know
summer 2020
things started to become clearer
i think a lot of people lost faith in
our institutions and our public health
officials
i'll say i'll say what happened for me
when those 1200 public health experts
signed the letter that said
um protests for racial justice are
a-okay during covert at a moment where
people still couldn't even go to work
and then at the end of the letter it
says this is not to be confused for
support of protests that are against
lockdown measures
i remember that i said okay i'm done
yeah yeah and i think a lot of people
were done at that point too
if you were so if you're a sheep you're
sitting there being like like a shout
out to ethan klein
hvapodcast when he said you know you got
to think you should you know you don't
got to think about it i think it's what
he said right like you know you got to
think about it yeah i never saw him say
it i've heard i heard you mention it
yeah it's like i guess on his podcast he
mentioned you can go to the cdc website
you don't got to think about it they
just tell you and it's like maybe you do
but hey look look
i'm not saying there's anything wrong
with being a sheep i want to make sure
that's clear i'm not insulting people
for being sheep there are a lot of
people i'm good friends of mine and i've
had really interesting philosophical
discussions where i've had people say
would i rather
be the one who's in charge of organizing
all of these people would i rather sit
back crack a beer and watch the game and
say i'm going to enjoy life and enjoy my
ignorance i'm like yo i can get i get
that yeah i can i can respect wanting to
revel in ignorance how i i i can
understand that personally i should say
this
uh when i say respect it i mean i get
that feeling
i understand
you know personally
i think people need to if they're
cognitive cognizant of what's going on
speak up and stand up there are a lot of
people who don't view it that way and
maybe don't have the ability to to see
what's really going on and maybe just
think to themselves look
i wake up i go to work i try to feed my
kids i come home i turn the tv on they
tell me what's up and that's all i care
about yeah i mean i mean there are
instances for instance right i'm i'm a
christian so in the scriptures it talks
about you know jesus is the good
shepherd and but part of what pastors
are supposed to do is shepherd their
flocks right so in that context i get
you know a shepherd
who who feeds his sheep but in that
context the shepherd is working under
the authority of the good shepherd
and they're feeding
um you know from a source
that
provides all the nutrients
that any of the sheep would need right
that's different than what we have
we have awful shepherds we have
uh shepherds in both wolf's clothing
which is worse than a sheep and wolf
clothing because if you get a sheep in
wolves clothing
you may the wolf may get one or two
sheep before the rest scatter but a
shepherd in wolf's clothing will take
all of them over the hill and none of
them will be we'll know the difference
well i think wait i i think you're
mixing it up wolf and shepherd's clothes
yeah
wolf's clothing so i'm like
the sheep pretended to be the wolf
uh i think we actually have sheeps and
shepherds clothing i think i think we've
gone so long without a real shepherd and
this could be even religious as well
like we've we've separated ourselves
from any real leadership that finally
one sheep looked around and was like yo
the shepherd gets to eat whenever he
wants to go every once correct i'm going
to put on the shepherd's you know i'm
going to i'm going to i'm going to carry
around his you know what would that
stick stuff
and just tell him what to do and so
you've got sheep leading sheep yeah the
blind leading the blind yeah and that's
the you know we're just talking about it
the the white knights
the uh is that the i guess the simps
the sims the guys who are just like
people that's kind of what it means what
it means
that's not what means i think it means
you're simple i think that's the idea i
think you're making that up i don't know
i don't know what else it would mean
means something i don't know but but it
just you know basically it's a guy who's
like white knighting for some for some
chick this is what we have in terms of
our leadership it's not just about the
woman it's about the constituency it's
about the politician being like
i'm just going to say whatever you want
to hear right because hopefully that'll
make you happy i think that you were
talking about people wanting to drink
beer and check out and watch the game
and like i get it but i think that we've
been groomed for this i think that the
whole bread and circus thing it's an
ancient roman tactic you want to keep
the plebes happy you just make sure they
have enough bread and they have enough
entertainment same with beer now you go
turn on tv and watch a sports football
game or something beer commercials car
commercials get get drunk buy a car so
like it's not healthy to check out
especially when people that check out
and then think they have some political
clout by putting a sign in their yard
and yelling at their neighbor about like
if you're gonna check out check out go
away yeah well i guess to clarify what i
was saying before about some people just
want don't mind being sheep and there's
something wrong with it is when you have
a good shepherd right then your flock is
protected correct doing what they gotta
do this country though it was definitely
founded on like don't ever give up your
rights don't ever check out you are this
process right but i'm not saying to give
up your rights i'm saying
you know some there there are people who
i i love using the example of like a
carpenter it's like a regular trade job
or an electrician let's say you're an
electrician man you will run circles
around me and explaining how all this
stuff works right i'm going to be like i
have no idea right so and i trust your
expertise right but at the same time
that electrician is going to say to me i
don't have time to read the news all day
and this is really important stuff i can
wire a house i can save your house from
burning down i can fix a car i can do a
lot of stuff i can actually i've had
electrons electricians talk about
creating you know wiring up crazy
devices and supercharging remote control
cars and doing really awesome stuff
because they know they know how to do it
so they need to rely on someone who's at
the forefront of the conflicts in the
world the culture battles right
journalists and politicians who are
going to say you got my back in terms of
building the infrastructure and i'll
make sure you're well informed and
prepared for what comes next right i
can't expect them to be where we are
that's what i mean when i say you know
everybody's a leader in some some
respect yeah but when it comes to our
actual political military and media
establishment that leadership is in the
gutter yeah it is a cesspool thoroughly
discredited and i mean
i remember one point i sent one of my
boys um
uh a tweet from the cdc because his his
wife was pregnant at the time
and it said something to the effect of
you know are you considering getting
vaccinated and these vaccines are now
available for birthing people what and i
said why would you trust a public health
establishment who that doesn't even know
who the category of person that can get
pregnant right the exclusive category of
person that can get pregnant as i said
all of these institutions have
discredited themselves over the past you
know two years they'll blame it on
alt-right they'll blame it on trump but
it's known you guys have done it um and
now you're feeling the backlash people
are waking up to it waffle sensei chimed
into super chat with the quote from
ethan klein he said the cdc is like this
whole government body with scientists
and ish that tell us what to do you
don't have to think about it dude yes
wow well there you go yeah that's
dangerous man because um
it's remarkable to me that you can look
at history with like asbestos come on
it's like not even hard to come up with
an uh
ddt is good for me remember remember
that
there was there's a really awesome ad
that was going viral was a pregnant
woman smoking cigarettes
wait yeah right yeah easy delivery
doctors recommend you know whatever
cigarettes for expecting mothers like
i think bill maher even mentioned this
too
maybe it's bill maher maybe it wasn't he
was saying that they was doing you know
drill mercury into your teeth they don't
do that anymore wow well i mean like
yeah we would get the fillings right
wasn't that like not even that long ago
they did lead fillings do they do that i
don't know yeah
yeah but they used to do they used to do
a bunch of a bunch of stuff and and all
the time we we we we
decided hey that was maybe a bad idea we
improved the science so to sit there and
be like
you know uh to quote biden the tuskegee
airmen experiment
but the uh the just the uh the tuskegee
experiments yeah like the government
mk ultra that was real it wasn't an
accident either that one was right i
know like
we know you don't just sit back and say
the government is my friend and
i think the government is is
inherently utilitarian it cares about
protecting itself correct and it cares
about maximizing output
it constantly shocks me how quick people
are to trust that the government has
their best interest in mind because if
you know anything about the government
you're gonna know a little bit about
like mk ultra and some of these other
weird projects and creepy suspicious
things the government's done i think
that people tend to lump that into the
whole alex jones paranoia basket but
these are very real things that have
definitely provably happened like the
tuskegee experience very real sure part
of the reason there's so much
vaccination hesitancy among that
community and it's like i completely
understand why they remember what
happened like that
that was funny to me because when the
new york vaccine mandates were all
happening they were black lives matter
activists protesting it and one of the
things i heard them say was like they
were like we remember what the
government did to us you're not gonna
just tell us we have to do this this
this ish you know what i mean yeah and i
remember
it's funny because the last time i came
i was talking about again another
article
and i think the title the title of it
was well kendy and biden
save no vax blacks from jab crow attacks
oh yeah that's right i remember that
and candy actually answered that
question someone asked him about the
vaccine mandates and of course i knew he
did what i knew he would do which was
pun you say oh well well they're really
not racist even though they have a
disproportionate impact because
uh blacks and hispanic and latinx can't
get um the vaccine they don't have
access one that's a lie two that would
make it even more racist if you're
holding
uh black and hispanic people accountable
for getting a a medical treatment that
you admit they don't have access to
but
again i knew that that's where he was
going to go because he's making way too
much money from you know guilty white
liberals yeah ever criticize them and
call them you know the forbidden r word
but
yeah it's for me one of the big things
the word that keeps coming back to my
mind as it relates to cover stuff is
authority
this this virus
has
um
made the populace give up authority in
areas of their private life
their medical lives that we've never
considered before and the government has
been more than willing to take it on so
now all of the my body my body my choice
people are now like no you must get the
vax you must and if you don't you're a
bad person the people who would never
stigmatize anybody for having aids or
hiv regardless of what type of personal
behavior they're engaged in are now
saying no
if you get covered and you're
unvaccinated you should die and you
shouldn't get medical treatment so
it's basically flipped
all of you know people's principles
right on their head thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm now don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you